Duct tape, originally called “Duck” tape,
was originally invented by Johnson & Johnson’s
Permacel division during WWII for the military.
The military specifically needed a waterproof
tape that could be used to keep moisture out
of ammunition cases.
This is why the originally Duct tape came
only in army green.
As to why it was originally called “Duck”
tape by the soldiers isn’t entirely known.
It is commonly thought that because it was
green and shed water, like a duck, the soldiers
took to calling the tape “Duck” tape.
An alternative theory is that they called
it thus because it resembled strips of cotton
duck.
Soldiers began noticing the tape wasn’t
just good for waterproofing ammunition casings,
but also worked great for repairing things.
They began using it for repairing jeeps, guns,
and aircraft.
Due to its waterproof nature, strength, and
built in adhesive, they even began using it
as a temporary means to close up wounds in
emergencies; this is fitting because the closest
predecessor of duct tape was also a Johnson
& Johnson medical tape product.
So how did “Duck” tape eventually come
to be known as “Duct” tape and be sold
primarily silver in color instead of army
green?
When the soldiers of WWII came home, they
brought “Duck” tape with them.
Shortly after their return, the housing market
was booming.
Some manufacture then got the bright idea
to start using the tape as a means to connect
heating and air conditioning ducts; this idea
caught on among home manufacturers and they
started using it in many of the new homes
being built.
To allow for this usage, the tape’s primary
color was switched from green to silver, so
that it would match the ducts.
Soon, the tape began being referred to as
“Duct” tape instead of “Duck” tape.
Ironically, researchers at the Lawrence Berkeley
National Laboratory, Environmental Energy
Division concluded that you should never use
Duct tape to seal ducts.
Their tests showed that under typical duct
conditions, duct tape becomes brittle and
will fail quickly.
Duct tape also can catch on fire or just smolder
and produce toxic smoke.
Because of this, it’s usage on ducts has
been prohibited by the state of California
as well as in building codes in most
of
the U.S.